[Musik]
rang
hallo ich habe euch vergessen zweiten
grades an kohlenstoff machen dienstag
sie steigen dann fällt er offen
dafür bräuchte ich wenn meine kamera
aber freunde der marienplatz der grund
bauen wir nach berlin fliegen also sind
übrigens am flughafen angekommen
düsseldorf und technisch lange drum rum
besser mal dein
[Musik]
das mag daran liegen dass ein flughafen
förmlich mit
vom fliegen wir hätten nicht nach berlin
bei einer ganz kurzen hinzu was sie
gerade überhaupt ab geht die sportliche
familien halten
hey jetzt liegen wir nach der in
brasilien beendet doch einmal gehen wir
zur passkontrolle am flughafen und
eigentlich normal wenn du von köln
achten die flicks musst du deinen fast
nicht vorzeigen und dann hab ich meiner
frau kate bose der eigentlich was ist
das hier gerade das ist eine tolle
überraschung gewesen von managements
main region abonnenten und jetzt sehen
wir weiter und ich musste mich dass wir
dahin fliegen wo wir jetzt fliegen
was also anscheinend viel mit nach
berlin sondern in london irgendwie ganz
plötzlich und keine ahnung warum
das habe ich mich wohl zu trinken
[Musik]
da betätige ich jetzt den rasen
es ist wichtig dass genervte der seite
immer klopapier benutzt das als idee
geld macht im fleisch und schauen dass
körper ständig davor die wolken dahin
dass wir alles kokain des bevor ich auf
toilette gegangen doch da hinten
irgendwo saß und jetzt hier vorne an
demenz und nehmen
neben uns informiert uns nichts
geschenkt
machen
lecker
heute gerade wir sind in eine
warteschlange
eingeleitet worden und die kreise
die luft bis wir landen wird
25 minuten später und wir sind noch in
der warteschleife in der luft über
london das erste wenn man beim kunden
soll das anrufen
da halten erwartet
das eigentlich das ganze
da irgendwas passiert mit einer der fall
ist
wir sind jetzt gerade mitten im flug
nicht nur innenstadt und es ist
natürlich am regnen
wir sind in london freunde und das
wetter es ist geil ich liebe das ist
mein gott wie sie ankommen unseren
kleinen aber feinen hotel zimmer haben
da vorne kommt man rein hier ist ein
fernseher da vorne ist im fernseher hier
pen wir hier ist das bistro kleines
update man jetzt auf hotelzimmer ich
habe mein video dort aufgenommen und
jetzt sind wir beim pcx oder ist
natürlich eine richtig schöne pizza und
hier vorne richtig festliche ja ich weiß
jetzt schon gesagt habe aber wir sind in
london weil ich eigentlich erst ab
berlin fliegen wollte mit hilde aber ich
dachte werden termine allerdings ist das
jetzt überraschungen drei millionen
abonnenten und da fahren wir jetzt hin
und das hat mir die ganzheitlich gesagt
und da fahren wir sind ok da müssen wir
in österreich ist natürlich nicht
vorstellen wir laufen die ganze zeit rum
und ich verkehr ja die eigentliche
zielgruppe aussteigen kann ich das
machen
treffen mit weise nicht
er sagt gar nicht ich habe mittlerweile
herausgefunden was man uns bei gehen wir
zum londoner stadtderby gegen chelsea im
um schnell ausverkauft
aber stehen sofort fließen
hasler tatsächlich 2 1 gewonnen und
steht damit jetzt im finale des spiels
jetzt vorbei also dort gewonnen stehen
damit im finale die ich gehabt schon
gesagt habe ich wollte nicht so viel
film wird hier im stadion waren weil das
ist ein bisschen dumm ganze spielfeld
mallya ihm versichert ist hat am handy
ja doch ins tor
naja ist luca hatte angeguckt dienstag
wir befinden uns jetzt auf jeden fall
dem taxi und fahren bzw stehen gerade
nach hause
die freunde gerade ein mega der zufall
wir laufen hier wirklich einfach so
dicht und treffe bei marias freunde herr
volkmann schau war freunde dass ich dann
direkt wäre hier sportlich ist wer hier
die treppe nimmt und wer schönen aufzug
genutzt übrigens wieder zurück im hotel
zimmer angekommen und das war die tür
wir sind zurück im gerät nicht hier sind
zurück im hotelzimmer dann gerade noch
steigen bewässerung senk ju gewahrsam
inter hier nebenan und haben uns da
etwas zu essen gekauft
ich habe uns ja einen ultra leckeren
reis gekocht und dazu ihr das schöne
hier alt ist da sind sogar noch die
stückchen drin wo ist das nicht toll ja
er wird unser essen aufgegessen was
willst du mich gekocht dank ihr ist
jetzt auf jeden fall gesetzlich und
werden jetzt schlafen gehen
das geil ist ich habe hier unten so ein
kissen und da vorne liegt deswegen trägt
er das voll in die fresse ich würde den
block an dieser stelle jetzt allerdings
auch beenden weil da vorne bisher nicht
mich schon einem spiegel dass das ist
deswegen würde ich sagen an dieser
stelle möchten wir wissen schon gesagt
ihr müsst euch einfach vorstellen wie
dieser tag für mich anfragen
beziehungsweise ablegen ich dachte jetzt
gingen nach berlin um irgendwelche
termine zu haben dann waren wir
allerdings nicht aber die geflogen
sondern nach london und jetzt war die
überraschung ist auch bei dem geilen
fußball spielbahnen jetzt schlafe ich
also vielleicht hat euch gefallen und
dann tschüss
[Musik]